e
what good morning everybody being 1119 I
guess we'll get started if I we can all
rise for the
pledge
all right again welcome to
Transportation before we get started on
our executive session on our final three
bills thank
you uh last time we were here on the
31st I mentioned the formation of a
subcommittee within the within our
committee and all committees to overlook
the uh
rules on a regular basis uh to make sure
that the rules that are being adopted
follow the intent of the legislation
that's being passed so I said I'd look
for
volunteers however in the meantime I was
told by the speaker office they need
names yesterday so I picked four people
oh who I thought would be
competent and more than eager to
participate in these subcommittees so
I'll mention the four that I've selected
and obviously if there's a problem let
me know I can make changes uh but
representative Sykes
uh representative
Gorski I knew I was going to get that
smile but it's better than a hit uh
representative
sellers okay
and I forgetting his
name and representative
V is everybody good with that so I got
lucky all right
more more information on that to follow
uh so hold on one second we'll get
started
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on Bill 375 FN relative to The
Lure of non-resident aliens temporarily
residing in New Hampshire chair
recognize as representative Gorski for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I like uh
my motion is to itl HB 375 motions itl
is there a second second seconded by
representative d uh did you want to
speak to it or do you want me to um I'd
like to speak a little bit to it thank
you Mr chairman um one of my big
concerns here with u hp375 is with
further testimony that we had uh several
weeks ago um I was quite concerned with
the lack of a vetting process the
temporary kind of vetting process was
not necessarily full extensive which
gets me concerned of we don't know who's
really here um in our state and for that
I'm very very concerned and I can't
really support this
Bill thank you sir anybody else from the
committee represent
SES so I I hear your concern but I think
the the a broader picture of way to look
at this is that um several points I
would make uh one is that under the real
id id procedures for instance the
federal government recogniz IES uh
filing for Asylum as a criteria that
would allow driver licenses to be issued
um not just for a temporary one like
this bill provides but for one that uh
matches for a normal uh course of
however long their permissioned to
remain in the United States uh is valid
for this bill is very limited in its
scope and it tries to take into
consideration of the fact that some of
the recent data that we've heard is that
um requests for Asylum are
taking uh decades literally to have
their hearings their formal hearings in
the meantime though persons who put in
requests for Asylum are required to fill
out paperwork where they say where they
came from why they came to the United
States what the basis of their Asylum
request was
for um and as a matter of course they
would receive a work permit which would
then allow them to get a driver's
license anyways the problem exists
that um under our current statutes a
person who moves in who lives in New
Hampshire of which an asy requestor
could be a citizen of this state
they are only they are required to get a
driver's license after I think IT
director correct me if I'm wrong but 60
days um and yet they can't because they
can't meet the
requirements And yet when they get their
work permit they can meet the
requirements and then they are duly
issued a New Hampshire driver's license
the problem is that even work permits
now are backed up to taking over a year
sometimes as much as 18
months and so even this bill
unfortunately was only looking at the
the oneyear delay but we're not
even we're not even being able to this
won't even be a full fix anymore but the
but the point is
um these folks are here
legally they have filled out the
appropriate paperwork and have been
temporarily vetted and then after one
used to be one year now it's a little
longer they are automatically
given um a work permit which then allows
them to get a driver's license I don't
see where this is such a heavy lift
where we're only trying to close the gap
between when you are required to get a
driver's license but
can't and are allowed to get a driver's
license and can't there's that Gap in
that's what this bill is attempting to
do and I again I don't see it as a big
heavy lift and I would urge my
colleagues to support um not support the
itl motion so that a further motion
could be
made anybody else from the committee
representative sers thank you Mr chair
so representative Sykes I heard you say
a couple things there that the person
that came over the Border has given
their
information from where they're from from
and you know they're they're they're
pertinent information to the government
the United States
government but they came over the Border
they didn't come in through the
checkpoints necessarily that okay all
right then the other part I want to
bring up is as you said it's this is not
a full fix this this bill won't totally
fix it so we're not we don't have a bill
that's totally baked yet it's not going
to it's only going to partially fix
something it's it's it's not going to be
all
there if I could respond you want to
okay representative SES I let you reply
thank you representative CIS for those
questions so one of the things I think
that
um we should be mindful of and this is
why I think it's really important too is
a Sil people who uh apply for asylum in
the United States who have filed the
necessary paperwork in order to get
themselves on a list so that they can
have a hearing
are incredibly mindful of how lucky they
are to be here they're incredibly
mindful of how careful they must be
because for the slightest reason their
ay request could be
denied and they don't want to do that
and so they are literally model citizens
and we we just there is virtually no
data showing that a s requests holders
of driver's licenses in this state or
any other state are a problem to Public
Safety or to furthering their need to
work and support their family and um to
make sure their children get to school
and they do all the things that
everybody would want a person who was
newly arrived in this country to do and
we know we live in a state New Hampshire
where public transportation is rare
enough anyways but in rural areas it's
incredibly rare and they are stuck in a
in a catch 22 that we could fix um this
committee could fix
um anybody else from the committee rip
resentative
Smith thank you Mr
chair we have a couple of statutes that
are in conflict and I'm just not going
to support a change to one without
fixing the whole problem the nature of
the conflicts is 263 39a is a standalone
statute as is 26340 a 26340 a says that
an applicant for a driver's license who
has not previously been licensed to
drive a motor vehicle in the state shall
provide his or her social security
number in the
application the applicant shall be given
the opportunity to determine whether or
not to have his social security number
retained in the records but that it's
explicit you have to have the social
security number now to 6339
a which is the statute that the bill
updates talks about people who probably
don't have a Social Security number so
how how do you allow these two to stand
when we have conf statutes that are in
direct conflict with each other often
the courts get involved because we
didn't straighten it out and in terms of
agency Administration a common practice
is you look at which one was updated
last and go with that and in this
case driver's licenses license
Reciprocity for aliens temporarily
residing in New Hampshire was last
updated June 21st 2003 the social
security number required statute was
August 8 20 9 I would really like to see
that fixed first another problem with 26
339a is we're creating a new
documentation requirement with this bill
but we're not getting rid of the other
ones in 263
39a they talk about the eligible people
in Roman numeral 1 and now in Roman
numeral 2 which is the real mess the
director may require any of the
following
and lowercase b is submission of social
security number or if the person does
not qualify for such a number the
submission of certification to that
effect as is acceptable to the
commissioner so how does the new Bill
affect that because that's standing
because it isn't a strikeout in the bill
and by the way the list of documentation
here most of which is proving that the
person actually knows how to drive
that's all optional now I believe the
director is trying to figure out if
these people can drive but he's not
required to and that's another problem
um he doesn't have to ask for any of
these so I'm just not going to support
an update to 263 39a which is a real
mess and a real problem thank you Mr
chair one more one more bite at it
representative SES well um I
respectfully to representative Smith
when one receives their work permit they
are also eligible and can get a Social
Security number at that time and so when
they go to the DMV they have a work
permit and a social security number that
will support their request for a
driver's license so
uh I just wanted you to know that that
that that is part of the process for
them anybody go ahead representa Smith
thank you clarify question so you you
said work permit but this deals with
just filling out an application for
Asylum status so you're saying at that
moment they're eligible for a social
security
number no no I didn't say that no I
believe when he said when they get a
work permit they'll be assigned a social
security
number thank you Mr chair representative
Jones Thank you Mr chair
um I'd be opposed to the itl um
I think we have protections built in
especially in uh section D um where it
says written acknowledgement of receipt
from United States citizenship and
Immigration Services shall Pro be
provided with the license application so
that means there is some vetting going
on and also we have the another
protection where a driver's license
issued pursuant to this sub paragraph
shall be valid for 180 days so they have
to go through I believe they have to go
through that whole same process again 18
180 days
later so we do have some
protections I I'll chime in at this
point just to clarify a few things based
on the research I've been doing uh when
you do when when a person comes through
a Port of Entry uh they're given
basically just a receipt uh and at that
time they are being told they are
lawfully present in the United States
because they entered through a Port of
Entry but that's all they've got uh to
pursue Asylum uh they have to continue
on their own that application
process what and that's only an
application what this bill seeks to do
is give them allow them to get a license
merely by applying for Asylum there is
no vetting that that takes that takes
place in that Asylum hearing so in
today's world I don't know why um it's
it's hard to see that the
mere applying for something is adequate
proof of vetting I don't see that it is
the the other and so I'm I'm happy with
it is I will not be supporting this the
other thing that I'll mention on the 180
days this was brought up in the original
hearing as a problem um only because
you're right if it's a year or better
before the work permit starts kicking in
these people could potentially get a
license for 180 days if this were to
pass then they would have none and then
I guess they have to go without driving
after they've been driving for 180 days
uh until they did get a work permit and
that whole process kicked in so so that
that's that was a problem that was
identified with this bill on day one uh
so that's another reason why I won't be
supporting it either uh anybody else
from the
committee representative Sellers and
we'll move on soon yeah thank you Mr
chair I just was wondering if um anybody
knew exactly how many Asylum Seekers
coming into the United States States
every
year I don't have numbers I mean other
than what we've all heard in the media
in terms of the millions uh but but I
don't have accurate
numbers specifically in New Hampshire
either anybody else seeing none um the
motion on the floor is itl on House Bill
375 I'll ask the clerk to call the RO
Vice chairman Gorski
yes representative Smith yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative Dum yes representative
gagy yes representative Boyd yes
representative C yes representative
sers yes representative Sykes no
representative Rich no representative
Sinclair no no representative
Fox no representative Rambo no
Representative viu no representative
Coker yes representative Jones no
representative
Davis
no and chairman
Walsh
yes
to8 okay our recommendation of
itl uh is adopted 118 I'll close the
executive session on House Bill
375 just a moment to
reset
all right first of all I apologize I was
remiss welcome to a few people from to
Transportation representative gagy it's
great to see you representative Boyd
thanks for coming representative Davis
welcome to
Transportation uh I'll open up the
executive session on House Bill 570 an
act relative to real ID compliant
enhance your driver's licenses chair
recognize uh representative Gorski for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I'd like to
uh make a motion of itl on HB
570 thank you is there a second motion
is
itl I'll second seconded by
representative Crawford just will let
you
know care to speak to motion yes um the
real ID is um can give um Asylum Seekers
even more uh
Privileges and beside the vetting issue
that we've kind of discussed um
regarding this bill one of the things
that caught my eye was on the dhs.gov
website under real ID one of the things
it states is that real ID allows
compliance states to issue driver's
licenses and identification cards where
the identity of the applicant cannot be
assured or for whom lawful presence is
not
determined that to me is a big huge red
flag that to me um screams that there's
not effective vetting in regards to this
whole P process and for that I cannot
support this
Bill thank you anybody else from the
committee represent
SES well
um I guess I the the I do have an
amendment if we get that far but um I
will suggest that um anytime
we can help the DMV and help the
population of New Hampshire to be
um compliant with reasonable federal
laws that's a that's a step that we
should take and this the amendment that
I have um does just that it brings Nampa
law
into uh conformance with uh federal law
relative to the requirements for the
issuance of a real ID it's as simple as
that and um I I just see that it's a way
that we should be going rather than
trying continuing to be um outliers in
terms of uh the way that we look at real
world problems for real world
people anybody else from the
committee representative
sellers Mr chair um I'm just reading
here a little bit and I'm just not check
my emails I'm I'm looking at this and it
says the real ID Act was uh in 2005 but
it started it came out of because of the
911 issue that we went that we had in
911 right and therefore we're trying to
make sure we know the identification of
these people to getting these IDs and I
don't think that's actually happening at
the border we we're not getting that
information
necessarily are you trying to say say
that federal law doesn't make any
sense rhetorically anybody else from the
committee uh you know uh for all the
same reasons I was opposed to 375 again
um I I do agree I was Jo joking a minute
ago real ID was put in place for
security purposes so we know who's who
but yet you read some of the the uh the
AC acceptable reasons for getting a
license it goes in the opposite
direction uh I'll leave it as simple as
that that I'll encourage the committee
to vote no on this it's way too vague uh
and uh I think we should leave it alone
and this does basically on line D bring
it up to the standards of the real ID
Act of 2005 Public Law
10913 so I'll leave it at that with
nobody else from the committee I'll ask
the clerk to call the
role a motion is
it Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative gag yes
representative Boyd yes representative C
yes representative cers yes
representative
Sykes no representative
Rich no representative Sinclair no
representative Fox no representative
Rambo no Representative veu no
representative Coker yes representative
Jones
no representative Davis no and chairman
Walsh
yes 11
to8 okay our recommendation of itl is
adopted
118 11
to8 um where was I a recommendation of
it was adopted 118 I'll close the
executive session on House Bill
570 and 650 next give us a minute to
reset
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 650 FN relative to
prohibiting suspension of driver's
licenses due to non-payment of fines or
fees chair recognizes representative C
for a motion
motion is to interim
study represent C moves interim study is
there a
second seconded by representative
Smith representative C care to speak to
your motion uh yes um this bill may have
uh may be appropriate if the conditions
for suspension were more carefully
written as it is a person with a fine
for a driving infraction could not have
their driving privileges suspended and
this is the most direct reason for
having a suspension is of driving
privileges for driving
violations um also consider that this
would only punish New Hampshire drivers
with uh reciprocity we can only suggest
to other states that they do so it may
not be in their priority to do so on
minor fines and stuff like that
thank you anybody else from the
committee represent
SES yeah so
um I would be in support of a interim
study bill because I think there is work
that we need to do um uh there are there
are members of this committee who have
supported uh not supported other
legislation which was taking driver's
privileges away for non-driver related
um
uh issues and we are we are I think uh
in support of the concept that we should
uh decouple you know uh loss of driver's
license because of issues that are not I
mean there are some federal laws that we
can't change and shouldn't change uh
child support being an example of one of
those but I think we could do more and
we can do better
um and so I I I'm hopeful that the
committee can uh pass the motion as it
is thank you anybody else from the
committee seeing none our motion is
interim study on House Bill 650 I'll ask
the clerk to call the RO when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
de yes representative gagy yes yes
representative Boyd yes representative C
yes representative sers yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Veo yes
representative Coker yes representative
Jones yes representative Davis yes
chairman Walsh yes 19 to
zero
our recommendation is adopted 190
interim
study consent do I hear a motion consent
consent been moved without objection
consent that is I'll close the executive
session on House Bill
and yeah well I just want to say thank
you everybody again uh that is our final
bill for the year we have our rules
committee set up our subcommittee set up
um I don't have anything else anything
for the good of the
cause have a great hollow representative
Smith thank you Mr chair if I may on the
um the rules subcommittee so we had
we've had some issues come up with
committees that already have those up in
working not producing a work
product the job is to produce a work
product and the question is probably a
little difficult for some it doesn't
matter if you like the underlying law or
not that's not your job and if you can't
separate that you're not suited for the
subcommittee the idea is to look at what
the existing law is and make sure the
rules consistent with it even if it's a
law you hate so you kind of have to
divorce your personal feelings about the
law from the process which is just does
the rule support the intent of the
legislation so I would ask the committee
please keep that in your mind as you go
through this it's not an opportunity to
relitigate the initial
anybody else all right thanks one more
time have a a good beginning of your
winter I guess I'll see you in
January
thank you on that
yeah one one last thing I I apologize
anybody that's got any reports do can I
get them before you
leave um I want to make sure everything
is submitted before we leave today I put
down
yes